the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about faith
of the Brotherhood without banners the
group that was indirectly created by
other Stark when he sent out the force
of knights to restore peace and justice
for the Riverlands which resulted with
them being trapped behind enemy lines
which led them to become a guerrilla
fighting group and I'm going to bring
you guys in your spoilers from Icelander
confirming a theory in the Jon Snow will
lead small force beyond the wall on a
mission to catch a white which will
resolve it Knight Kings ambush firstly
I'm going to focus on faith of Lord
beric Dondarrion the leader of the
Brotherhood without banners
also known as the Lightning Ford I'm
going to focus on fate of two more
members of the Brotherhood I'm going to
focus on faith of tours a red priest of
the Lord of Light from the free city of
Muir and on state of a new member of the
Brotherhood on fate of Sandor Clegane
called the hound who join the
Brotherhood in the end of season six and
then I'm going to bring Union spoilers
from Iceland let's start with the leaked
plot which says the beric Dondarrion
Taurus and the hound will be part of a
small force a part of John Cena is going
to try to catch white in favor to prove
Daenerys and rest Westeros that the real
war is coming and that is to one between
the living and dead apparently on that
mission Taurus is going to be killed by
a zombie polar bear but before all of
this even happens according to leaked
plot the hounds Toros and Varrick are
going to be locked in a jail by
tournament in this video I'm going to
explaining all of this I'm also going to
show you the proof that are going in
favor to leak plot but before I get into
this I'm going to give you a few tears
of mine a few theories in which I'm
going to try to solve a few questions
for example how and why the Brotherhood
without banners is even going to join
John on his mission okay let's start
with a conversation between Varrick and
hound a conversation in which beric
recruited Sandor Clegane to their newest
mission which is traveling north to
fight against the great evil as you said
it seems that they have already planned
to go north to fight the undead army but
the question is how and why are they
going to join John the question on which
most of you would say that
they are simply going to meet up since
all of them are heading north but you're
wrong they are all heading north
true but the Brotherhood without banners
is traveling by the land while John
relates his team beyond the wall on his
mission by the sea in a boat as
confirmation for this statement we have
leaked photo in which we clearly can see
that John Davos Jorah and ginjury push
the boat and run together away after
Dave over the Manta dragging stones
John ginjury Davos and Jorah will travel
by the scene about meaning that they
will make a step on the ground before
they make it to the wall meaning that
they will travel to his voyage by the
sea east which by the sea the castle and
port located at the far eastern end of
the wall where the wall drops into an
inlet of the Shivering sea called the
bay of seals eastwatch-by-the-sea is one
of only three man castle slapped on the
wall along with Castle black and the
shadow tower in novels is specified at
King Stannis Baratheon also landing with
his forces at eastwatch-by-the-sea when
he came to the wall to save the Nights
Watch
so the question still remains and it's
why and how the Brotherhood without
banners is going to join John and rest
of his team on that mission well I might
have an answer on that question we all
know the Melisandre is heading south and
if you watch my previous videos you
would know that she will encounter Arya
Stark but before that happens no Sanju
will meet up with products could fade
out banners and that's the answer on our
question
that's why Brotherhood will join John on
his mission by mightier email Sanjay
will tell to barrack and tourists the
John is the one the one that is promised
the one that Lord of Light brought back
to life as their conversation continues
and as materi continues Melisandre will
commence Barrick and towards that John
is the plains that was promised and sits
well known that both of them obey
commands of the Lord of Light I can
assume that it won't take long for most
Andrey to convince them to go north to
the wall and help John in his mission
Commission which tourists will die a
mission that will resolve this whole
Westeros knowing about the real threat
the results with almost every Lord
sending their armies to the north I
think that I don't even have to tell you
that very can tourists along with hound
will definitely go to the north after
this
counter with Melisandre since beric
Dondarrion and Taurus believing the Lord
of Light furthermore Barry has died six
times only to be revived by Taurus Samir
sprayers to the Lord of Light berrak was
killed six times first time by the hand
of sir gregor clegane during the battle
the mummer's Ford second time he got
stabbed in the belly
third time Barry died from the arrows
shot at in his back four time and nax
had driven into his side fifth time
Barry Coast captured by Lannister
soldiers who decided to execute him for
treason but unable to decide whether to
hang him or stick a dagger to his eye
they just did both and the last six time
Sandor Clegane killed barek during a
trial by combat and it seems that we
finally know the reason of him being
revived all six times which is most
likely because of John's mission because
Barry still has something to do for the
Lord of Light as Lake Blatt says they're
going to be part of John's team which is
by my theory because I miss Andre
according to Lake plot of heading north
the Brotherhood will be captured by
tournament could lock them in a jail
which I'm not sure why there are a lot
of possibilities for an example because
simply of tournement outing in their
intentions now here's the second answer
on our question from the very beginning
firstly I explained you the reason of
the Brotherhood without banners joining
John the remaining question is how are
they going to become part of John's tini
they are locked in a jail it's actually
very simple there are a few possible
ways but most likely one is Center
releasing barrack tourists in the Hound
since she knows that the Lord beric
Dondarrion is the lord of Blake Haven
and the head of house and area the house
that was loyal to house breaking on of
storms and in the man who had a group of
soldiers to apprehend Sir Gregor Clegane
the man who did that because of her
father because Ned Stark commanded since
Samson of the Bears loyal to her father
who at a time of hand of the king and
since she knows who Sandor Clegane
really is I'm a who try to save her once
a man who wanted to ask or Sansa to the
north as she refused the same girl who
is now a woman will this time believe to
the hound and since you know the very
key is an honorable and trustworthy man
since
set them free that's the moment in which
beric Dondarrion is going to lead the
Hound and tours to the wall since John
is going to be there at a time John
along with Jorah dousing injury as I've
already said will sail to the east which
by the see the castle located at the
eastern end of the wall there from they
are then going to proceed west along the
north side of the wall until they reach
Castle black castle black will be the
place on which John will gather his team
and go on white hunting while apparently
Dallas will stay over there and wait
John will form a small force which will
contain obviously him as a leader
ginjury Jorah who joined him at
Dragonstone torment as a man who knows
lands beyond the wall and knows how to
move over there berrak tours and hound
as the prone fighters while the Lord
said willingness to help them now let's
get first into spoilers from the
Northern Ireland a spoilers that made
this theory from a liquid into a
confirmed one spoilers century that I
brought you guys almost 40 days ago in
my video about Jon Snow's fate and then
I'm going to bring you guys a brand new
spoilers from the Iceland I'm going to
bring you once again new and leaked
photos aka spoilers that are confirming
a theory in which John is leading his
team beyond the wall to capture white in
favour to prove the in Ares and the rest
of Westeros that the true war is just
about to come to read that also says
that they are going to be noticed by the
night King and later are going to be
attacked by his army on the icy surface
which will result with Torres getting
killed by the rest of John's team will
be saved by Danny and her dragon all
except John who is going to be
surrounded by horde of the undead army
but then all of a sudden benjin will
appear and they'll save his wounded
nephew by standing Jon on his horse
while he's going to stay to fight and
will die as a hero this theory has been
refused by so many fans but as time
passes more and more proofs are going
favor to this theory before we get on a
photo in which we clearly can see pol K
to us known as tourists of mere angel
Dempsey aka ginjury let's see all
spoilers that are confirming this theory
firstly we witness creating the new sad
by Game of Thrones crew at Wolf's Hill
query mobile fest Game of Thrones crew
has blanked the area with fake
No and created an artificial Isis
surface rather like in I still awake
along with a large green screen with
snowy ground beneath it
after that there appeared leaked photos
with even harder proof as in first one
we can see the unit of lights in this
room a set about Balthus which they were
preparing for a few weeks for the
shooting three hundred extras had been
brought on this size is set now this
photo still didn't confirm much but then
more leaked photos came from Belfast
with even more proofs the second photo
also goes in favour to this theory as we
can see three main characters that had
never crossed paths in previous season
but are now together just like teary
says and guess where are they journey
Belfast I've already taken this theory
is confirmed one after this photo which
was taken at restaurant in Belfast the
photo in which we can see Ian Glen on
the Shora Christopher Hill journalist or
moon angels at mol known as Benjen stark
heaven great time at restaurant
let me repeat this to you these
characters have never crossed paths in
previous seasons but now we're together
in Balthazar filming set as they
surpassing even more and more proofs
were coming keep Harrington also appear
in Belfast as this so a lot of photos
taken by fans and then also appeared
lonely forward or from the shooting set
but it's quality is way too low in my
opinion it's John preparing for filming
on this size is sad but if the world is
to allow I cannot guarantee you guys if
it's John Snow about a forty days ago I
said that we're only waiting for Emilia
Clarke to appear in Balthus which will
be the final confirmation for this
theory
well we were waiting for Emilia to
appear in Belfast for about a month but
we don't have to wait anymore since she
appeared in Belfast a week ago we won't
have any Lea photos of Emilia Clarke aka
the neighbors from the shooting set
since she will soon her scenes only
cited Titanic studios I have told me
that I didn't need any more proof for
this theory but Bruce continued coming
and still are coming few days ago Game
of Thrones has returned in Iceland for
the filming of the upcoming season to
shoot icy landscape set in the frozen
north of Westeros to continue shooting
this match King's ambush on John and his
team which began shooting in northern
Island at Wolf Hill quarry Bob alphas
and is now continuing filming in Iceland
firstly Game of Thrones crew landed with
Star Kit Harington
aka Jon Snow while a directors Phil are
are these days the shooting is expecting
to last a couple of weeks as a
confirmation that is shooting in Iceland
will represent scenes of John and his
team beyond the wall we have a photo in
which we can clearly see Joe Dempsie aka
ginjury + Paul K aka tours a photo that
is taken by a fan in Iceland this folder
is only confirming this theory even more
confirming the tours who most likely
died in the upcoming season confirming
that the Lord of Light revived beric
Dondarrion all six times because he
needed him needed him to unite round
with the Brotherhood needed him to lead
the Brotherhood without banners to join
John in his mission to help him and also
confirming virtual tours a words
restored said to the Hound which were
the Lord of Light escaping barrack alive
for a reason hope you guys enjoyed this
video if it is please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one
[Music]